a fugitive caught in a legal tug of war
more than 70 mps and peers mostly labour
are calling on sajid javid to ensure
julian assange is
extradited to sweden to face a rape
allegation
but the us wants the wikileaks founder
who was dragged from the ecuadorian
embassy on thursday
extradited to face computer hacking
charges
after he published american government
dossiers
alleging iraq war crimes the mps who've
written to the home secretary
claim the rape allegation which mr
assange denies
is more urgent because it expires in
august next year
we do not presume guilt of course but we
believe
due process should be followed and the
complainant should see justice be done
what we know those of us who have worked
with survivors of sexual assault
is that any man can um perpetrate a
sexual crime
and that they shouldn't be given special
treatment if they are
famous for another reason
jeremy corbyn attending labour's welsh
conference
wants the government to block mr
assange's extradition
to the u.s if there are allegations
which julian assange needs to answer
of um sexual issues
sexual attacks that may or may not have
taken place in sweden
then it's a matter for the courts to
decide but i do think you should answer
those questions
my objection was to his expedition to
the united states
because i do believe that wikileaks
told us the truth about what's actually
happening
in afghanistan and in iraq sajid javid
may well have to make a decision
about whether to prioritize a swedish
extradition request
or one from the united states in doing
so he considered first of all
when a warrant was issued and secondly
the relative seriousness of the alleged
crime
lawyers say it's the rape allegation
that's more
serious they would be looking at the
length of imprisonment and the rate the
maximum
term of imprisonment is life whereas the
maximum term of imprisonment for
computer
hacking as charged by the us
is five years but the legal process
could take up to
three years before mr assange is put on
trial
john craig sky news